learning objectives by the end of this
lesson you will be able to describe the
importance of continuous integration and
continuous deployment list the features
of Jenkins and demonstrate their uses
list the features of team city and
demonstrate their uses and select a
suitable tool for your organization the
overview and importance of continuous
integration and continuous deployment
overview of continuous integration
continuous integration as a development
practice of combining code from a number
of different developers into a common
code base intended for deployment each
integration event is verified by
automated build and automated tests
there are many aspects to a continuous
integration also known as CI process
continuous integration is a development
practice of combining code from a number
of different developers into a common
code base intended for deployment each
integration event is verified by
automated build and automated tests
there are many aspects to a continuous
integration also known as CI process
these are develop and compile code
perform unit tests integrate code with
various types of databases perform
pre-production deployment activities for
example moving code to various types of
computing environments such as testing
and staging also part of a continuous
integration process is to perform
functional testing and apply labels
against release points in the code
repository additional activities in CI
are to generate reports and analyze the
code continuous integration is about
combining code from each developer into
a common deployment path automatically
with a high degree of accuracy
continuous integration is more than a
developer just creating some code and
committing it to a feature branch he or
she is working on for automation to pick
up and deploy instead the developer
needs to make sure that he or she writes
unit
that exercise each line of code written
the purpose of unit testing is to prove
that the code that's written works the
expectation a standard feature of most
shops that practice continuous
integration is to have the process run
all the unit tests in the developers
work branch before merging the code into
a common code base
if the unit tests don't pass in the
automated process the developers code is
not merged into the common branch then
the developer is typically notified
either by email or by another
communication channel that there's a
problem that needs to be corrected
overview of continuous deployment
continuous deployment is an extension of
continuous integration its purpose is to
reduce the time between a development
team writing code and then using it in
production the benefits of continuous
deployment are not only that it provides
faster feedback from end users as each
new feature is released to production
but it also realizes a faster return on
investment for each feature as it gets
developed for the most part continuous
deployment is a highly automated process
that reduces the need for human
interaction in the deployment process
scripts take over most of the work that
used to be done by humans previously
involved in the physical deployment of
code not only does automation copy code
from one computing environment to
another the scripts will actually create
the computing environments that need to
be in place before you can move the code
along automation reduces the time it
takes the get code from developer to
end-user
and increases the accuracy of the code
that's being produced continuous
deployment makes sure that the right
code is in the right place at the right
time
popular tools and continuous integration
and continuous deployment the more
common CI CD tools use an IT shop
practicing DevOps R Jenkins Travis CI
bamboo team city and get lab continuous
integration with Jenkins Jenkins is one
of the more popular tools in the DevOps
landscape
it's a powerful framework that supports
a broad plug-in ecosystem instead of
having to write code on a line by line
basis to extend the power of Jenkins
developers write custom plugins to add
new functionality these plugins are
highly reusable so much so that a whole
marketplace has evolved around the
product there are now over a thousand
plugins available and most of these are
free also Jenkins integrates with over a
hundred other DevOps tools such as
github and testing tools from a variety
of vendors Jenkins allows DevOps
personnel to reliably orchestrate the
release tool chain and it's designed to
be an end-to-end solution in order to
get full benefit from using Jenkins
aspiring DevOps personnel need to
understand the standard phases in the CI
CD pipeline these phases are code and
commit build and configure scan and test
release and deploy you're going to
incorporate of a variety of tools with
Jenkins during each phase of the process
during code and commit developers use an
integrated development environment also
known as an IDE to create code the
popular ones are Visual Studio Visual
Studio code and Eclipse and then they'll
check the code into a version control
system such as yet github perforce or
mercurial some code might require binary
dependencies that are stored in an
artifact repository such as artifactory
after code is created and committed it
needs to be built if the code requires
compilation into a binary file such as
DLL Exe or jar file Jenkins will use a
build system such as ms build a C
compiler maven for Java or ant for more
general purposes if the code needs to be
containerized you'll use docker some IT
shops will automatically create
computing environments during building
configure in anticipation of impending
code deployments tools such as puppet
chef and ansible can provision virtual
machines automatically according to
predefined configurations in during the
scan and testing phase you'll integrate
Jenkins with testing tools such as J
unit J meter cucumber or MS test
front-end testing can be conducted using
selenium appium sauce lab or EULA Packer
products the purpose of scan and test is
to make sure the code meets quality
standards and is safe to move forward in
the C ICD process the release phase is
the last stage before code is released
to users you might integrate Jenkins
with tools such as you deploy sarena mid
vision or Excel release finally for
deploy you'll go on premises to a cloud
service or a hybrid combination of both
a private on-premises cloud and a public
cloud for public cloud deployments
you'll target Amazon Web Services cloud
Azure or IBM cloud also we're seeing
cloud orchestration technologies such as
kubernetes take an increased presence as
a release platform for a private cloud
there's OpenStack if you're working
directly with virtual machines you'll
integrate Jenkins with VMware products
or a docker at a high level in terms of
application runtimes you'll need
something like the JBoss java virtual
machine or the websphere application
server jenkins provides operational
consistency and the various stages of
release regardless of the particular
products you plan to use thus you'll do
well to keep these phases of deploying
in mind as you continue on your journey
to DevOps mastery
continuous deployment with Jenkins as
you can see in the slide continuous
deployment which we abbreviate a CD
consists of five operational stages the
first stage is coding which is typically
done on the developers local workstation
the next stage is storage during the
storage phase a developer commits his or
her code to a source control management
system such as get moving the code into
a separate test computing environment
ensuring that the code is implemented in
the best way possible in addition to
ensuring that the code works according
to expectation so that it can be
released to production is done in the
quality assurance and testing stages
production is the final stage in the
release process production is where the
code is made available to end-users
the value that Jenkins brings to the
software development lifecycle is that
it can be configured to automate every
stage of the entire process this is very
important because it not only speeds up
the software development process overall
but also increases the accuracy and
reliability of the code under
development companies such as LinkedIn
Google and Facebook have made continuous
deployment a fundamental part of the way
they make software it's only by using an
automation tool such as Jenkins that
effective continuous deployment is
possible doing deployment manually is
time-consuming and costly those who
adhere to the principles of DevOps
understand that continuous deployment is
an essential part of the practice of
software development in the modern
enterprise and automation is key to the
practice continuous integration with
teamcity teamcity is a free continuous
integration tool from JetBrains the
company is best known for its integrated
development environments for writing
software the abbreviation for integrated
development environment is IDE
teamcity is a complete continuous
deployment continuous integration system
designed to automatically manage all
aspects of the software development
lifecycle teamcity is designed to
integrate with all the popular products
used in modern software development it
integrates well with the standard web
browsers as we've learned previously
communication among and between teams is
important thus teamcity can be
configured to send out notifications
using email RSS chat tools and social
media platforms such as slack
it supports version control by
integrating with source control
management systems such as get
subversion perforce as well as many
others teamcity supports all the build
tools and development frameworks
commonly found in the enterprise such as
ant maven msbuild and grunt also
teamcity can be integrated with popular
ide such as eclipse the various jet
brain tools such as IntelliJ webstorm
and pycharm teamcity also integrates
easily with the industry standard for
developing Microsoft technologies visual
studio and visual studio code continuous
deployment with teamcity a good way to
understand the workflow that teamcity is
designed to manage by way of automation
is to conceptualize the software
development process as having three
areas of activity artifact deployment
and operations let's take a look at each
area in detail our artifact activity is
about managing the various code
components that make up a software
system some shops use the term
deployment unit to describe the distinct
component of code that needs to be
released into production other shops use
the term deployment artifact some of
these components might be a binary file
such as Java or a jar file or in dotnet
shops the artifacts can be an exe or a
DLL file Linux doesn't have the concept
of file
extension based executables thus any
file can be an executable you just need
to have the right permission set the
important thing to understand about the
artifact area is that it's about
creating and managing deployment units
that will be released to production
deployment once an artifact or a
collection of artifacts are ready for
release they need to go through a
company's deployment process there are a
number of tools and processes associated
with deployment activity the ultimate
goal of the deployment activity is to
make sure that working valuable software
gets to the customer as quickly as
possible typically companies will use a
ticketing system to control and monitor
the work that needs to be done in
deployment artifacts will be prepared
for deployment computing instances will
be provisioned sometimes the
provisioning might involve creating
virtual computing instances such as a
virtual machine or container other times
it might require installing physical
Hardware such as computers and
networking devices then after
provisioning is complete the deployment
artifacts are configured and pushed into
relevant computing environments and
finally we get to operations it's
important to understand that a
comprehensive CI CD system such as
teamcity goes beyond just deployment
activity team city will also automate a
lot of operations activity release
personnel can use team city features to
orchestrate computing environments and
monitor activity in those environments
also it coordinates important aspects of
enterprise level DevOps such as logging
and aggregating security alerts security
is a critical aspect of any enterprise's
operation and is a particular concern to
any DevOps practitioner working within
the enterprise overview and features of
Jenkins Jenkins as a continuous
integration tool
Jenkins is a java-based open-source
automation tool it functions as a server
and is a software development and
cross-platform tool used for continuous
integration and continuous deployment
let's look at what Jenkins can do as a
continuous integration server it can be
used as a CI server or a continuous
delivery hub for a project in terms of
distribution it can easily distribute
work across different machines and help
trigger builds test and deployments to
multiple machines and platforms quickly
jenkins is designed to work
cross-platform it allows programming in
software development environments such
as iOS Net Android Ruby and Java
architecture of Jenkins Jenkins is a
comprehensive CI CD framework that is
designed to be flexible and extensible
it has a distinct object model that has
classes like project and build these
classes describe the various components
of the framework it uses jelly as the
view technology it uses the file system
to store its data directories are
created at the location on disk defined
by the environmental variable jenkins
underscore home it supports plugins
which are plugged into those extension
points and extend the capabilities of
Jenkins popular features of Jenkins
let's take a look at the features one
Jenkins is platform independent - it has
a rich plug-in system 3 it has the
support of a large community of
third-party developers and expert users
4 it's designed to scale to meet the
needs of the large enterprise 5 its
automation capabilities enable immediate
detection and resolution of issues 6
it's open source and user friendly and 7
it's easy to configure modify
they extend build status and job health
every time a Jenkins job runs the status
of the build gets reported the figure on
the left side of the slide shows the
results of a few runs of a built project
notice that the result of each build is
reported
sometimes the build succeeds other times
it fails if an administrator aborts or
disables the build that gets reported to
the figure on the right side of the
slide provides a description of the
overall health of the project according
to many builds assisted practice set up
Jenkins
let's take a look at the assisted
practice you are given a project to
install and configure Jenkins on the
Ubuntu operating system of your learning
lab virtual machine lab 3.1 installing
and configuring Jenkins in this demo
we're going to describe three steps to
install and configure Jenkins first
we're going to modify the file sources
that list then we're going to use
apt-get to install the Jenkins package
and then finally we're going to run
Jenkins in the browser so let's get
started first at the command line we
type make der lab 3.1 then the command
line we type cd' lab 3.1 to navigate
into the directory we've just created
now we need to add the key from the
Jenkins package repository into our
local environment at the command line we
type WK - Q - o HTTP colon slash slash
package Jenkins dot IO
slash
Debian - stable slash Jenkins IO - key
pipe sudo apt - key ad - and this will
add the key directly into the apt-get
filesystem now we need to update the
file sources that list will use the by
editors that's already installed in your
classroom virtual machine at the
command-line we type sudo space VI space
/e t c /a PT forward slash forces dot
list sources that list is the file that
act get uses to locate package
repositories on the internet we strike
the I key on the keyboard to put Vai
into insert mode we scroll down to an
empty space and VY and type Deb HTTP
colon forward slash forward slash pkg
Jenkins dot IO forward slash Debian -
stable space binary forward slash then
we hit the Escape key to get out of
insert mode and type : w for right Q to
quit by now we have to update the
package manager at the command line we
type sudo apt - get space update update
execute once we see the line reading
package lists dot done the update is
complete now we need to see if Java is
installed and if not we need to install
it at the command line we type Java
space - version as you can see
Java and the Java development kit is
already installed
if Java was not installed you type sudo
space apt - get space install space o PE
n JD K - 7 - j j r e this command will
execute app get to install the open JDK
package now we install Jenkins type sudo
space apt - get space install space
Jenkins
strike the Y key to confirm installation
the installation process will take a few
seconds now we're going to open the
initial installation of Jenkins in a
browser we go back to the virtual
machine desktop in this case we'll load
the Firefox browser
we're going to enter the IP address of
the Jenkins installation the IP address
was assigned to the virtual machine
earlier in the address bar of the
Firefox browser we enter the IP address
1 7 2.3 1.2 6.2 34 colon 8080 8080 is
the port where the Jenkins server is
running please be advised the IP address
of your virtual machine will be
different and no way you can discover
the IP address is at the command line
type ifconfig the IP address of your
virtual machine will be in the
information displayed the first screen
where shown is the unlock Jenkins screen
we're going to need to enter the
administrator password
in order to continue as you can see in
the red type the location of the
password is a file slash var slash live
slash Jenkins slash secrets slash
initial admin password where initial
admin password is the name of the file
that contains the password we return to
the terminal we type clear to clear the
screen at the command-line we type sudo
space cat space forward slash far
forward slash live forward slash Jenkins
forward slash secrets forward slash
initial admin password we strike the
enter key to display the password we
highlight the password in the terminal
and then copy it by right-clicking on
the mouse and selecting copy we return
to the browser and paste the password
into the administrator password text box
then we click the continue button
Firefox will offer to save the password
but we'll click don't save we have the
option to install suggested plugins or
we can select specific plugins to
install we're going to go with the
install suggested plugins method we
click the box labeled install suggested
plugins the getting started page appears
and the plug-in installation continues
once downloading and installing the
plugins is complete you'll be presented
with the create first admin user page
at this point we've successfully
installed Jenkins now the next steps
will be to create the admin user by
putting in a username password
confirmation of password a full name for
the user and the users email address
let's recap the important steps justed
practice guidelines to install and
configure Jenkins log into Ubuntu lab
provided with the course open the
terminal and execute the command
available in the lab document 3.1 to add
the key to the system edit the sources
that list file and add the command to
the file and then save it update the
apt-get package install JDK 8 plus
version installed Jenkins using apt-get
package now vacate to the IP address of
the machine to note it as X point X
point X point X colon 808 O in the
browser of your virtual machine get the
password and enter it into the Jenkins
window create a new role job in Jenkins
Explorer the Freestyle project and build
section overview and the features of
team city team city as a continuous
integration tool team city is a Java
based management and continuous
integration server it's licensed
commercial software that's used for
continuous integration and continuous
deployment team city supports a number
of features that are important to the
continuous integration process for
example David commits ensure only
working code is committed to deployment
branches in source control team city
supports integration with various
integrated development environments such
as Eclipse and IntelliJ it has a build
grid that describes build activity also
it has cross platform support for a
variety of operating systems and
programming languages also team citi has
seamless code integration
teamcity workflow team city supports the
CI CD process that has become the
standard workflow for many companies and
software development shops let's take a
look at the overall workflow as you can
see in the slide at 0.1 the first step
is that a developer or tester checks
code in to the source control management
system upon commit at point to a build
trigger message is sent to the team city
server then at point 3 team city works
with system unit testing to start the
system unit testing automation process
if the code passes the test artifact
building archiving and deployment tasks
are performed in an automated manner at
point for team city reports the status
of all the activities at point five
popular features of team city team city
has many features that make the CI CD
process more efficient let's take a look
at the features team citi has pre-tested
commit instant notifications it has code
coverage and monitoring capabilities it
provides a comprehensive build
infrastructure and it has enhanced
version control system integration team
city makes it easy to verify code and it
offers configurable test reports and
finally team city supports managing
users and roles assisted practice setup
team city now it's time to do an
assisted practice to set up team city
you're going to be given a project to
install and configure team city on the
Ubuntu operating system in your learning
lab virtual machine so let's get started
with lab 3 point to install and
configure teams city
first we create a directory for the work
we type MK dir lab 3.2 then we navigate
to that directory by typing CD space lab
3.2 first we're going to download the
compressed GZ file for team city then
we're going to extract the files from
the compressed file we're going to move
the extracted directory that contains
the files into another location we're
going to start up team city and then
we're going to go to the browser and
register a user with team city let's
download team city we go to the desktop
of our classroom virtual machine and
then we click on the icon for google
chrome chrome appears in the chrome
address bar we type WWJ our INSCOM
forward slash teamcity forward slash
download we click the download button GZ
file downloads and the Thank You page
appears we return to the terminal at the
command line we type CD space forward
slash home forward slash Ubuntu forward
slash capital downloads forward slash we
strike the Enter key this takes us to
the directory where the GZ file has been
downloaded at the command line we type
LS to confirm that
GZ file is indeed in the directory
notice the file team city - 201 8.2 dot
one dot r dot GZ is listed now we need
to extract the files at the command line
we type T ar space z XV f space team
city - 201 8.2 dot one dot r dot GZ and
we hit the enter key this will extract
all the files into a directory named
team city now we need to move the
directory team city into the directory
/opt forward slash JetBrains we create a
directory by typing sudo space mkdir
space /opt forward slash capital jet
capital brains now we need to move the
directory team city into the directory
/opt forward slash JetBrains at the
command-line we type sudo space MV space
team city space /opt forward slash
JetBrains forward slash team city we
strike the enter key now we need to give
full read write and execute permissions
to the files in the newly created
directory team city
at the command-line we type CD space
/opt forward slash JetBrains we strike
the Enter key then we type chmod space -
capital R 777 teamcity forward slash
this says to give all rights to the
directory and the contents of the
directory teamcity we type LS just to
make sure the directory teamcity is
indeed there we type CD space team city
forward slash and hit the enter key to
enter the directory team city then we
type LS to take a look at the contents
of the directory team city notice there
is a bin directory
we navigate into the bin directory by
typing CD space bin and hit the enter
key let's clear the screen to make
things easier to see to invoke team city
we will execute the bash file dot
forward slash team city - server dot Sh
space start it's very important that you
use the dot forward slash characters we
hit the enter key and team city starts
up spawning team city and then team city
restart ur running with PID one one six
one eight and the PID the process
identifier will vary according to
systems now team city is running we go
back to the browser but before we do
take notice of the IP address of the
virtual machine which is shown on the
command line on the left hand side the
IP address of this virtual machine is
one seven 2.3 1.26
dot two three four in the address bar of
the Chrome browser we type one seven 2.3
1.26 dot two three four : 8 1 1 1 which
is the port on the IP address where team
city is running the team city first
start webpage appears we click the
proceed button the team city is starting
page appears then we see the database
connection setup page team city allows
you to choose from a variety of
databases we can use Postgres my sequel
oracle or ms sequel server we're going
to use the internal database team city
creates the database and initializes its
server components this phase of the
setup can take a few minutes the page
will reload automatically once team city
is through installing its server
components we're almost done with team
cities installation process then all
we'll need to do is to create an account
in team city when the installation
process is complete we'll be presented
with the licensing agreement that we
have to agree to we scroll to the end of
the terms and conditions
we click the checkbox for accept license
agreement we're going to uncheck send
anonymous usage statistics then we'll
click the continue button the web page
create administrator account appears we
enter the user name simply learn then we
add a password and confirm the password
finally we click the button create
account we'll also save the user name
and password information in Google
Chrome upon successfully entering a
username and password will be presented
with the my settings and tools web page
in teamcity
the page allows us to access projects
and changes and agents as well as build
queues in the next demo we'll look at
more details let's recap the important
steps
guidelines to install and configure team
city number one login to YouTube unto
lab provided with the course number to
download team city from the official
site 3 unzip the folder and install team
city
4 provide the read write and execute
mode access to seem City number 5 run
team city at X dot X dot X dot X colon 8
1 1 1 where X dot X dot X dot X is the
IP address of your local machine or the
machine where the server is running 6
create an account in team city and add
the basic details to complete the setup
process 7 explore options such as
projects changes agents and built queue
build tools and their uses build tools
build tools are programs that automate
the creation of applications from source
code automation tools allow the build
process to be more consistent some
common build tools are make bash which
ships with Linux and Apache maven for
Java grunt and gulp popular features of
build tools well we can start with
compiling two binary code for languages
such as C sharp and Java build tools
will package a compiled program for
deployment also it'll run automated test
cases against the code your build tool
will deploy artifacts to production and
will also generate documents for
developers to use for later reference
and finally a build tool will generate
release notes an overview of apache ant
apache ant is a java library and
command-line tool its aim is to provide
processes described in build files as
targets and extension points dependent
on each other let's take a look at some
of the distinct features apache ant
supplies a number of built-in tasks that
allow it to compile test and run
it's flexible and does not impose coding
conventions it builds solutions by
combining bill tools and dependencies
with Apache IV it solves makes
portability problem and users can
develop custom ant lives using Java and
finally you can use ant to pilot any
type of process the limitations of
Apache ant and Apache ant there are a
few limitations some of the limitations
are number one configuration error
checking is limited undefined properties
are not raised as errors but are left as
unexpanded references number two and has
limited fault handling rules lazy
property evaluation is not supported
thus you need to be very exact when
configuring it it is not a forgiving
environment number three older tasks use
default values which are not consistent
and can cause problems you need to pay
attention
changing defaults can break existing ant
scripts and finally number four and
build files are complex and verbose as
they are hierarchical and partly ordered
an overview of maven Apache maven is a
comprehensive software project
management tool based on the project
object model also known as the pom maven
can manage a project's build reporting
and documentation from a central XML
file let's take a look at the key points
of maven number one is backward
compatibility and auto parent versioning
the hierarchical structure of the
pom.xml file reduces the burden on
version control and reconciliation of
dependencies number two maven supports
model-based builds number three maven
supports parallel builds and better
error integrity reporting you can kick
off a number of project builds that run
asynchronously number four release
management and disk
and publication is built into Mayman the
project object model is comprehensive
and covers all aspects of the software
development lifecycle from development
through testing and on to release number
five instant access to the latest
features with less or no additional
configuration may even allows artifact
version control that can be set to get
the latest release of a dependency thus
you can make sure the code is always up
to date six large and growing
repositories there is a complete
ecosystem of maven artifact repositories
that make it so you have access to
popular components automatically the
maven repository found at HTTP / / maven
repository comm is a popular one also a
company can set up its own private
repository the drawbacks of mavin mavin
does have some drawbacks number one
unable to depend on outcome status maven
builds can fail leaving nothing behind
other than error messages that can be
very hard to understand number two
maven is verbose and complex it does
take a while to master the details of
the platform number three slow and
partial blackbox
maven does a lot of things automatically
and sometimes these black box activities
can be very opaque and finally number
four
maven can be unreliable when integrated
for use within the Eclipse IDE comparing
maven over ant
well maven has better dependency
management it provides more powerful
builds there's better collaboration and
the debugging capabilities are a bit
better than ant there's more
componentization in the builds and
there's reduced duplication and finally
the palm provides a more consistent
project structure the project object
also known as the palm the project
object model is an XML representation of
a maven project it provides general
configuration information such as a
project's name its owner and its
dependencies on other projects the XML
XAR in the slide shows a rudimentary
implementation of mavens project object
model the pom.xml needs to define the
group ID the artefact ID and version the
packaging needs to be declared to the
default deployment package is a jar the
project described in the XML file on
this slide has an artifact idea of
calculator you can think of the artifact
ID as the name of the artifact that's
going to be created the palm shows a
version of 1.0 and it belongs to the
group with the identifier EU dot total
eclipse you can think of the group ID as
a way a company organizes a number of
artifacts under a common name
overview of grunt grunt is a JavaScript
based task runner which is used to
automate repetitive tasks in a workflow
can be used as a command-line tool for
JavaScript objects let's take a look at
some of the key points to understand
about grunt and in front developers
write grunt setup files to ease workflow
thus grunt speeds up the development
flow and enhances performance it helps
with the automation of repetitive tasks
with less effort it supports a small
infrastructure which is a best fit for
new code bases grunt minifides files
such as HTML and CSS thus reducing the
potential problems with network latency
grunt aims at reducing the chances of
errors during repetitive tasks and it
includes built-in tasks to extend
functionality of plugins currently grunt
has over 4,000 plugins and can be used
in large production sites an overview of
gulp gulp is an open source JavaScript
toolkit used as a build system in
front-end web development it automates
time-consuming and repetitive tasks
involved in development some of the key
features of grunt are Code minification
and concatenation usage of pure
JavaScript code grunt converts files
created under less or sass and a CSS
compilation process less which stands
for leaner style sheets is a dynamic
preprocessor stylesheet language that
can be compiled into cascading style
sheets also known as CSS and these style
sheets are run on the client side or the
server side sass is a preprocessor
scripting language that is interpreted
or compiled into cascading style sheets
grunt also manages file manipulation in
memory some of the advantages of grunt
are that it's easy to code it's easy to
test with web apps and the plugins are
simple
use some of the disadvantages of grunt
are there's more than the usual number
of dependencies multiple tasks cannot be
performed in parallel and configuration
can become tedious assisted practice
continuous integration with Jenkins and
maven you are given a project to
configure in Jenkins you need to make
Jenkins Paul get commits and build the
project code using maven on the Ubuntu
operating system on your practice lab VM
ok so let's get started with lab 3.3
continuous integration with Jenkins get
and maven in this lab we're going to
configure Jenkins to support get and
maven then we're going to configure a
maven project and then finally we're
going to build the maven project using
source code from get so in a web browser
we open Jenkins and what we do in our
classroom virtual machine is we go to
the IP address and in this case it's 1:7
2.3 1.2 6.23 4 colon 8080 and Jenkins
typically runs by default installation
we click the new item link which is on
the upper left of the Jenkins web page
the new item web page appears in the new
project text box we enter the project
name in this case Java maven then we
select freestyle project then scroll
down the WIPP then scroll down the web
page and click the ok button on the left
hand side the web page for the newly
created project loads we add text to the
description text box this is a simple
project to test Jenkins we go to the
menu bar at the top of the projects web
page and we click the build tab we're
taken to the build section of the web
page we click
the ad bill step button to display a
drop-down of options from that drop-down
list we select the item execute shell in
the command text box we enter the Linux
command echo space quotation mark hello
space from space jenkins quotation we
click the Save button on the lower left
now
we'll do a test build to make sure
everything's working all right on the
left hand side of the project web page
we click the link build now the build
starts and when it completes you'll see
a blue circular icon in the build
history section of the project web page
on the left side and you can see there's
a build there and it's labeled number
one to the right of build number one is
a drop-down arrow which we click to get
a list of options and we select console
output selecting console output will
display in the web page the build log
activity notice there's a line that says
hello Jenkins this is from the echo
command we entered in the Jenkins build
configuration let's develop the project
a little more what we need to do is to
add get integration and get the project
to work with maven we go to the simply
learn site on github and that's simply
learned DevOps official and we go to the
repository Java maven app on the github
site we click the green clone or
download button to display the URL that
we can use to access to access the Java
maven app repository on github so we
highlight the URL and cob
we go back to the Jenkins web page and
the Jenkins web page on the menu bar we
click the tab for the Java maven project
the Java maven project appears on the
left side of the projects web page we
click the configure hyperlink this loads
the project's configuration page in
which we click the source code
management tab we're navigated to the
source code management section of the
configuration page there we click the
option tip we paste the URL of our
simply learn Java maven app repository
into the textbox repository URL entering
a valid URL will make the error message
please enter get repository disappear
we're going to select some predefined
credentials from the credentials
drop-down we added those earlier but if
you need to add credentials in the
future simply click the Add button and
then select Jenkins now if you're using
your own github repository you'll be
presented with the Jenkins credentials
provider dialog you're going to need to
enter your user name and also your
password once we configure access to the
get repository we click the Save button
now what we've done is we've effectively
given Jenkins the right to access our
github account using our credentials in
other words Jenkins is impersonating us
after we save the get configuration
we'll be brought back to the projects
page we need to go back to Jenkins home
we click the Jenkins tab on the upper
left of the project page this takes us
back
to the main Jenkins dashboard page which
we can think of as home now we click
manage Jenkins on the left side of the
Jenkins home page on the manage Jenkins
page we select global tool configuration
the global tool configuration page
appears we scroll down to the Maven
section of the global tool configuration
page we click on the button add maven to
add a maven configuration we're going to
give this installation a name and we're
gonna call it local maven then may even
needs to know where its home is on the
classroom virtual machine in the text
box labeled maven underscore home we
enter the value slash USR slash slash
maven an alternative method is to again
click on add maven add a name this time
maven and then from the install from
Apache drop down select the version of
maven that's on the machine we've now
let Jenkins know about maven so we can
click the Save button we return to the
manage Jenkins page we need to return to
the project in the upper left hand
corner of the manage Jenkins page we
click the Jenkins button
we're brought back to the Jenkins main
dashboard you can see Java maven in the
list of projects on the main dashboard
when we hover over Java maven we'll see
a down arrow we click that down arrow
and some options appear we select
configure from the options drop down the
Java maven projects configuration page
appears we click the build tab in the
menu bar you can see the echo command
that we created previously in the build
section we want to get rid of it so what
we're going to
do is we're going to go to the right
side of the execute shell section and
click the red button with the X label
clicking the red button deletes the
execute shell command echo from the
build section now we want to add a new
build step we click the add build step
button and we notice that another
drop-down appears from that drop-down we
select invoked top-level maven targets
after we add the maven build task will
be presented with a maven version drop
down this will contain the maven
configurations we created previously we
select one of the configurations in this
case we'll select the maven let's recap
the important steps assisted practice
guidelines to configure Jenkins and
maven number one login to Ubuntu lab
provided with the course number to login
to Jenkins and create the first Jenkins
job number three install and configure
maven number four configure Jenkins with
Java get and maven number five created
Jenkins job for your maven build project
and run the project number six Pole get
four commits and automatically trigger
the build number seven build the trigger
using the push mechanism instead of pull
number eight repeat step six and seven
multiple times to observe the results in
the console output section
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here